تحاول الأمم المتحدة كسر
الجمود الدبلوماسي الخاص بها فيما يتعلق بالحرب
بين إسرائيل وحماس يوم الخميس، ألقى
سفير إسرائيل كلمة أمام
الجلسة الطارئة للجمعية العامة بشأن
الأزمة، ولم يتمكن مجلس الأمن حتى
الآن من التوصل إلى نفس الصفحة
حول ما يجب فعله بعد ذلك و
في الواقع، قد تصوت الجمعية العامة يوم الجمعة على قرار وقف إطلاق النار الذي
صاغته الدول العربية.
قال السفير الإسرائيلي إن وقف إطلاق النار
لن يؤدي إلا على حد تعبيره إلى تقييد
أيدي بلاده، وهي ليست محاولة
لتحقيق السلام، لكن
الممثل الفلسطيني رد على ذلك مطالبًا بسقوط
جميع الضحايا تقريبًا.  من بين
الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية مدنيون، أعرب الرئيس جو
بايدن في الواقع عن شكوكه
بشأن عدد الضحايا في
قطاع غزة الذي تسيطر عليه حماس، الأمر الذي أثار غضب
الفلسطينيين، وتلقى الأردن
تصفيقًا نادرًا من القاعة بعد هذه
الكلمات، نحن نهتم بحياة جميع
المدنيين المسلمين والمسيحيين
الفلسطينيين واليهود.
تحدثت جميع أرواح الإسرائيليين عن إنقاذ الأرواح
أصدرت إيران تهديدًا مستترًا
حذر وزير خارجيتها من أنه إذا
لم توقف العمليات العسكرية الإسرائيلية في غزة فإن
الولايات المتحدة لن تنجو من النار،
كما ادعى أن حماس مستعدة
لإطلاق سراح رهائنها المدنيين لكنه
زعم  ويجب على العالم أولاً أن يحث إسرائيل
على إطلاق سراح آلاف الفلسطينيين
من سجونها